ce que je dis c'est que booba a eu le
mérite de soulever un lièvre ou
gilles verdez cetim quoi toi excusez-moi
m division moi je sui team booba mais ce
qui me dégoûte c'est d'être en retrait
kepu
qu'est ce que vous venez [ __ ] ici
c'est qu'on n'est
jamais la réponse qu'est ce que je viens
faire là c'est beau jeu les invités
effectivement les besoins d'une
expertise que vous n'avez pas été foutu
de données voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était la mode des antilles vague
serait-il à éructer maintenant booba est
à la mode et le soutien plutôt vous êtes
a hérité dans une semaine casquette à
l'envers vous chantez durable et vision
[Applaudissements]